J’ai environ 18 minutes
pour vous convaincre que l’histoire a une direction -- une trajectoire.
Et que fondamentalement, c’est bien
que cette trajectoire tend vers quelque chose de positif.
Quand l'équipe de TED m’a contacté pour faire ce discours optimiste - -
(Rires)
-- c’était avant que la caricature de Mahomet déclenche d'importantes polémiques.
C’était avant que la grippe aviaire atteigne l’Europe.
C’était avant que le Hamas gagne les élections palestiniennes,
qui ont suscité de nombreuses réactions en Israël.
Et honnêtement si j’avais su, lorsque l'on m'a demandé de faire ce discours optimiste,
que tout en le faisant,
l’apocalypse serait en train de se dérouler
(Rires)
J’aurais pu dire, « Est-ce-que je peux parler d'autre chose ? »
Mais je ne l’ai pas fait. Et nous voilà, et je vais faire ce que je peux (bis).
Je dois vous prévenir:
l'optimisme qui caractérise ma vision du monde a toujours été assez subtile
voire même insaisissable.
(Rires)
Ma façon d'être optimiste et enthousiaste --
je veux dire, il y a toujours eu un côté sombre
dans ma manière d’être optimiste, donc si l'optimisme sombre --
(Rires)
donc, si l’optimisme sombre n’est pas une contradiction en soi, j'ai bien peur, que ce soit
ce que vous pouvez espérer de mieux. Ok, aujourd’hui- - c'est-à-dire si j’y arrive.
Je vais voir ce que je peux faire, ok ?
Alors, dans un sens,
l’idée que l'histoire a une direction n'est pas si controversée.
Si vous ne parlez que de structure sociale,
OK, clairement c'est devenu plus complexe
ces10 derniers millénaires -- cela a atteint des niveaux de plus en plus élevés.
Et en fait, cela soutient
une tendance de longue date qui précède l’être-humain, ok
que l'évolution biologique était en train de faire pour nous.
Parce que ce qui c'est passé au début, ces trucs se mettent dans une cellule,
puis ces cellules commencent à se réunir en sociétés.
Finalement elles se rapprochent tellement, qu'elles forment des organismes multicellulaires,
ensuite on obtient des organismes multicellulaires complexes, qui eux, forment des sociétés.
Mais ensuite à un moment donné, un de ces organismes multicellulaires
fait un truc tout à fait incroyable avec ça :
elle lance un deuxième type d’évolution : l’évolution culturelle.
Et étonnement, cette évolution suit la trajectoire
que l’évolution biologique a établi vers une plus grande complexité.
Par évolution culturelle on entend l’évolution des idées.
Beaucoup d’entre vous ont entendu le terme « memes ». L’évolution de la technologie,
à laquelle je prête beaucoup d’attention, vous savez,
l’une des premières choses qu’on a eu est une petite hache.
Les générations passent, et quelqu’un dit : hé, pourquoi ne pas la mettre sur un bâton ?
(Rires)
Et cela rend les petits fous de joie.
C’est ce qu'il y a de mieux après un jeu vidéo.
Ce n'est peut-être pas impressionnant,
mais l'évolution technologique est progressive, donc dans les 10, 20, 000 ans à venir
la technologie de l'armement vous amènera à cela.
(Rires)
Impressionnant. Et l’évolution technologique s'accélère,
un peu plus de 25 ans après, vous obtenez ceci, OK.
(Rires)
Et ceci.
Je suis désolé, c'était une blague facile, mais j'ai voulu trouver un moyen
de faire la transition pour retourner vers l’apocalypse qui se déroule,
et j’ai pensé que ça pourrait le faire.
(Applaudissements)
Bien. Ainsi, ce qui risque d'arriver avec le déroulement de l'apocalypse,
c’est l'écroulement de l'organisation globale de la société.
Maintenant, laissez moi vous rappeler combien de temps cela nous a pris pour arriver là où nous en sommes,
sur le point d'être une réelle société mondialisée.
À l'origine, les sociétés les plus complexes: le village de chasseur-cueilleur.
Stonehenge est le vestige d'un chef-lieu
qui est ce qu’on obtient avec l’invention de l’agriculture : un état composé de plusieurs villages
avec une autorité centralisée.
Avec l'invention de l’écriture, apparaissent les villes. C'est flou. J'aime bien,
cela fait penser un peu à un organisme unicellulaire qui vous rappelle
par combien de niveaux l'organisation biologique est déjà passée
pour arriver à ce point. Et ensuite vous, vous arrivez aux empires.
J'insiste sur le fait que l'organisation sociale peut transcender les frontières politiques.
C'est la route de la soie qui a relié l'empire chinois et l'empire romain.
Donc il y avait une complexité sociale qui couvrait tout le continent,
même si aucune politique était identique. Aujourd'hui, il y a des Etats-Nations.
Bien évidemment il y a une collaboration et une organisation qui existe
au-delà des frontières nationales.
Ceci est une photo de la Terre la nuit,
et je la montre parce que je trouve que c'est beau.
Elle traduit l'idée que c’est un système intégré.
OK. J'ai expliqué la croissance de la complexité en référence à quelque chose
que l’on appelle "somme-non-nulle"
Partant du principe que certains d'entre vous n'ont pas fait leurs devoirs, vite fait
l'idée principale est la distinction entre les jeux à somme nulle, dans lesquels les corrélations
sont inversées : il y a toujours gagnant et un perdant.
Dans les jeux à somme-non-nulle les corrélations peuvent être positives, OK
Par exemple au tennis, généralement c'est victoire/défaite
qui donne toujours à une somme nulle-nulle, mais si vous jouez en double,
la personne qui joue avec vous, est dans le même bateau,
donc vous jouez à un jeu à somme-non-nulle avec elle.
C'est pour le meilleur ou pour le pire, OK
Beaucoup de formes de comportements de somme-non-nulle dans les domaines économiques et autres
coopèrent souvent dans la vie quotidienne.
L'argument que j'avance est essentiellement
que les jeux à somme-non-nulle ont toujours fait partie de la vie.
Vous les retrouvez dans les sociétés de chasseurs-cueilleurs
mais ensuite avec l'évolution technologique, de nouvelles formes de technologies surgissent
qui facilitent ou encouragent la participation aux jeux à somme-non-nulle
impliquant plus de monde sur un territoire plus étendu.
La structure sociale s'adapte pour prendre ça en compte et
pour exploiter cette production potentielle, vous avez des villes,
où vous trouvez tous les jeux à somme-non-nulle auxquels vous ne pensez pas
qui se jouent à travers le monde.
Par exemple, avez vous déjà pensé que lorsque vous achetez une voiture
combien de personnes de continents différents ont contribué
à la fabrication de cette voiture? Ce sont des gens en réalité
avec lesquels vous jouez à un jeu de somme-non-nulle.
Ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il y en a plein autours de nous.
Cela semble être une perception du monde intrinsèquement optimiste,
parce que quand vous pensez à non-nul, vous pensez gagnant-gagnant
ce qui est bien. Mais, en réalité plusieurs raisons
font que ce n'est pas intrinsèquement optimiste.
Avant tout, cela peut s'adapter: ça ne dénie pas l'existence
des guerres basées sur l'exploitation des inégalités.
Mais il y a une raison essentielle
qui fait que ce n'est pas intrinsèquement optimiste, car un jeu de somme-non-nulle,
dit seulement que les coïncidences seront corrélées pour le meilleur ou pour le pire.
Cela ne prédit pas nécessairement une issue gagnant-gagnant.
Donc dans un sens, la question est, pour quelles raisons
je reste optimiste sur toute l'histoire? Et la réponse est,
avant tout, tout bien considéré je dirais que les gens ont joué leurs jeux
plus dans l'optique d'une issue gagnant-gagnant que dans une issue perdant-perdant. Tout bien considéré,
je pense qu'au niveau historique le résultat net est positif pour les jeux à somme-non-nulle.
Et un témoignage de cela est la chose qui me surprend le plus,
qui m'impressionne le plus, et qui m'inspire le plus,
c'est qu'il existe une dimension morale à travers l'histoire,
il y a une trajectoire morale. Nous avons vu que la morale a évolué avec le temps.
Il y a 2500 ans, les membres d'un village grecque
considéraient les membres d'un autre village grecque comme des sous-hommes
et les traitaient en conséquence. Et puis, cette révolution morale est arrivée,
et ils ont décidé qu'en fait, non, les grecs étaient des être humains.
Ce sont juste les perses qui n'étaient pas totalement humains
et ne méritaient pas d'être traités décemment.
Mais, c'était un progrès- ils avaient du mérite. Et de nos jours,
nous avons vu d'avantage de progrès. Je pense-j'espère-que la plupart des personnes ici diraient
que tout le monde est un être humain,
qui mérite d'être traité avec respect,
à moins qu'il ne fasse quelque chose d'horrible, indépendamment de sa race ou religion.
Et vous devez relire l'histoire pour comprendre à quel point c'est une révolution,
OK. Ce n'était pas un point de vue dominant,
il y a quelques milliers d'années, et j'attribue cela à cette dynamique de la somme-non-nulle.
Je pense que c'est à cause de ça qu'il y a davantage de tolérance envers les nationalités,
les groupes ethniques, religieux, aujourd'hui. Si vous me demandez,
par exemple, pourquoi je ne suis pas favorable au bombardement du Japon,
eh bien, je ne plaisante qu'à moitié quand je dis "ils ont construit ma voiture", OK.
Nous avons cette relation de somme non-nulle,
et je pense que cela mène à une sorte de tolérance dans la mesure où vous réalisez
que le bien-être de quelqu'un d'autre est positivement corrélé avec le vôtre.
Vous êtes plus susceptibles de leur lâcher du lest.
Je pense que c'est une sorte de moralité de business-class.
Malheureusement, je ne voyage pas en business transatlantique assez souvent
pour le savoir, ni sur d'autres vols d'ailleurs.
Mais je suppose qu'en business, vous n'entendez pas beaucoup
d'intolérance envers des groupes raciaux ou ethniques,
parce que les gens qui voyagent en business sur des vols transatlantiques
font du business avec tous ces gens; ils gagnent de l'argent
grâce à ces gens. Et je pense vraiment que dans ce sens au moins,
le capitalisme a été une force constructive,
et plus fondamentalement, c'est une somme-non-nulle
qui a été une force constructive dans l'ouverture populaire
de la conscience morale, OK. Je pense que la dynamique de la somme-non-nulle
n'est pas spécifique au domaine économique -- ce n'est pas toujours du commerce --
mais elle nous a amenée au bord d'une vérité morale,
qui est l'équité fondamentale pour tout le monde. C'est ce qu'elle a fait.
Comme elle a évolué, elle nous a amené à une organisation sociale mondiale
qui nous a conduit vers une vérité morale.
Je trouve ça merveilleux.
Maintenant, revenons au déroulement de l'apocalypse.
Et vous pouvez vous dire OK tout ça c'est bien joli
ça a l'air super-- la trajectoire morale de l'histoire --
mais qu'en est-il de l'affrontement des civilisations ? Et bien, premièrement,
je tiens à souligner qu'il s'inscrit dans le cadre d'une somme-non-nulle,
D'accord. Si vous regardez la relation
entre ce qu'on appelle le monde musulman et le monde occidental --
deux termes que je n'aime pas, mais que je ne peux pas vraiment éviter --
avec si peu de temps, ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire.
C'est une somme-non-nulle. Et par ça je veux dire que
si les gens du monde musulman deviennent plus haineux, plus rancuniers,
moins satisfaits de leur role dans le monde,
ça sera mauvais pour l'occident. S'ils sont plus heureux, ça sera bon pour l'occident.
Donc c'est une dynamique de somme-non-nulle.
Et je dirais juste que la dynamique de somme-non-nulle va s'intensifier au fil du temps
à cause du développement technologique, mais s'intensifier de manière négative.
C’est la corrélation négative des coïncidences qui sera de plus en plus possible.
Et une des raisons est ce que j'appelle la létalité croissante de la haine.
Il est de plus en plus possible pour la haine à l'étranger
de se manifester sous forme de violence organisée sur le sol américain.
Et ça c'est assez nouveau, et je pense que ça va probablement empirer
-- cette capacité -- à cause du
développement des technologies de l'information, celles qui peuvent être utilisées
à des fins de munitions, comme la biotechnologie et la nanotechnologie.
Peut-être en entendrons nous encore parler aujourd'hui.
Et il y a quelque chose qui m'inquiète particulièrement , qui est,
cette dynamique qui va entrainer un feedback rétroactif qui nous met sur une pente glissante.
Ce à quoi je pense, est: le terrorisme a lieu ici, nous réagissons de manière excessive.
Et nous ne sommes pas suffisamment prudents dans nos représailles,
ce qui conduit à plus de haine à l'étranger et plus de terrorisme.
Nous réagissons de façon excessive car étant des êtres humain, nous voulons nous venger
et cela devient pire, et de pire en pire.
Vous pourriez appeler ça le feedback positif des vibrations négatives
mais je trouve que pour quelque chose d'aussi effrayant,
nous ne devrions pas utiliser le mot positif, même dans un sens technique.
Donc appelons ça la spirale mortelle de la négativité.
(Rires)
Je vous assure que si ça fini par arriver aussi bien l'occident
que le monde musulman aura souffert. OK.
Alors, que devons nous faire ? Premièrement nous pourrions en faire plus dans le contrôle des armements,
et de la réglementation internationale des technologies dangereuses.
J'ai tout un sermon sur la manière dont le monde est gouverné
que je vais vous épargner maintenant,
parce que de toute manière je ne pense pas que cela soit suffisant, même si c'est essentiel.
Je pense qu'on va avoir une vague importante
de progrès moral dans le monde.
Je pense qu'il va falloir voir moins de haine entre les groupes,
moins d'intolerance, et moins de groupes racistes, religieux, et autre.
Je dois admettre que je me sens bête en disant cela.
Ca peut sembler candide. Je me sens comme Rodney King en disant :
pourquoi ne pouvons nous pas tous nous entendre ?
Mais, je ne vois vraiment pas d'alternative étant donné la manière dont j'interprète la situation.
Il va devoir y avoir un progrès moral, d'accord.
Il va devoir y avoir une diminution de la haine dans le monde,
vue à quel point cela devient dangereux.
Je dirais, pour ma défense, qu'aussi naïf que cela puisse paraître,
in fine ce n'est fondé que sur du cynisme.
C'est à dire --
(Rire)
-- merci, merci. C'est à dire, souvenez-vous : ma vision globale
de la moralité est qu'elle se rapporte qu'à l'intérêt personnel.
C'est quand les destins des gens sont corrélés.
C'est quand ton bien-être contribue au mien, que je décide, oh oui,
je suis entièrement en faveur de ton bien-être. C'est ce qui est responsable
de la croissance du progrès moral jusqu'à maintenant,
et je dis qu'une fois de plus on a une corrélation des fortunes.
Et si les gens répondent intelligemment, nous verrons
le développement de la tolérance et ainsi de suite --
bref, les normes dont nous avons besoin.
Nous verrons l'évolution future de cette moralité de type business-class.
Donc, ces deux choses, vous savez, si elles retiennent l'attention des gens
et mettent l'accent sur la corrélation positive et qu'ils font ce qui est dans leur propre intérêt,
ce qui développe l'évolution de la moralité,
alors ils pourraient vraiment y avoir un effet constructif.
Et c'est pourquoi je mets dans le même panier la létalité de la haine croissante
et la spirale de négativité mortelle sous la rubrique générale:
des raisons d'être heureux.
(Rires)
Je fais de mon mieux, ok.
Je ne me suis jamais appelé monsieur "Optimiste".
Je fais ce que je peux.
(Rires)
Lancer une révolution morale doit être difficile n'est-ce-pas ?
Je veux dire, qu'est ce qu'on fait ?
Et je pense que la réponse est que beaucoup d'individus différents
vont devoir faire beaucoup de choses différentes.
Nous démarrons tous là où nous sommes. En tant qu'américain
dont la sécurité de ses enfants dans les 10, 20, 30 années à venir
me préoccupe -- personnellement ce que je veux faire
c'est comprendre pourquoi tant de gens à travers le monde nous détestent, OK.
Je trouve que c'est un projet de recherche qui a de la valeur.
Ca me plaît aussi parce que c'est intrinsèquement un type d'exercice moralement rédempteur,
Parce que pour comprendre pourquoi quelqu'un
dans une culture très différente fait quelque chose --
quelqu'un que vous considérez comme étranger --
qui fait des choses que vous considérez étranges
dans une culture qui vous semble étrange, comprendre réellement pourquoi ils font
les choses qu'ils font, est une réalisation moralement rédemptrice
parce que vous devez vous identifier à leurs expériences.
Pour vraiment comprendre , vous devez dire, "Oh, j'ai pigé!
Ainsi quand ils éprouvent de la rancune, c'est un peu comme
quand moi aussi j'éprouve de la rancune
et un peu pour les mêmes raisons." C'est une réelle compréhension.
Et je pense que c'est un développement de votre sens moral quand vous y arrivez.
C'est particulièrement difficile à faire lorsque les gens vous détestent, OK,
parce que vous ne voulez pas vraiment
comprendre pourquoi les gens vous détestent.
Je veux dire, vous voulez entendre la raison, mais vous ne voulez pas vous identifier à celle-ci.
Vous ne voulez pas qu'elle ait un sens, pas vrai ?
Vous ne voulez pas dire, "Eh bien, oui, je peux comprendre
comment un être humain dans ces circonstances
détesterait le pays dans lequel je vis." Ce n'est pas une chose agréable,
mais je pense que c'est une chose à laquelle nous allons devoir nous habituer et
travailler dessus. Maintenant, je tiens à souligner que pour comprendre,
il y a des gens qui n'aiment pas tout ce processus de compréhension
le fondement, l'origine des choses ; ils ne veulent pas savoir
pourquoi les gens nous détestent. Je veux comprendre cela.
La raison pour laquelle vous essayez de comprendre pourquoi ils nous haïssent,
est de les amener à cesser de nous haïr, OK. L'idée
quand vous pratiquez cet exercice de moralité de réellement commencer à apprécier
leur humanité et de mieux les comprendre, c'est une partie de l'effort
pour les amener à apprécier votre humanité sur le long terme.
Je pense que c'est le premier pas vers cela. C'est l'objectif à long terme.
Il y a des gens qui s'inquiètent de ça, et en fait,
j'ai moi-même, apparemment, été dénoncé à la télévision
il y a deux ou trois soirs à cause d'un éditorial que j'ai écrit.
C'était quelque chose dans la même lignée, et l'allégation était
que j'ai, je cite : "de l'affection pour les terroristes."
Maintenant, la bonne nouvelle est que la personne qui a dit cela était Ann Coulter, OK.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Je veux dire, si vous devez avoir un ennemi, faites en sorte que ce soit Ann Coulter.
(Rires)
Mais ce n'est pas une préoccupation dingue, OK, parce que comprendre le comportement
peut mener à une sorte d'empathie,
et cela peut rendre un peu plus difficile d'être dur en amour, etc.
Mais je pense nous avons plus de risques de ne pas comprendre
clairement la situation, plutôt que de la comprendre si clairement
que nous ne pourrions plus nous résoudre à utiliser l'armée contre les terroristes.
Donc je ne suis pas vraiment inquiet à ce sujet. Donc --
(Rires)
-- je veux dire, nous allons devoir travailler à de nombreux niveaux, OK,
mais si nous réussissons -- si nous réussissons -- puis une fois de plus,
la somme-non-nulle et la reconnaissance de la dynamique de la somme-non-nulle
nous forcera à atteindre un niveau de morale plus élevé.
Et une sorte niveau de moral élevé salvateur,
quelque chose qui sauve réellement le monde.
Si vous regardez le mot "salut" dans la Bible --
l'usage Chrétien qui nous est familier
c'est en sauvant des âmes, que les gens vont au paradis -- c'est en fait une idée récente.
Le sens premier du mot salut dans la Bible concerne le salut du système social.
"Yahvé est notre Sauveur," signifie 'Il a sauvé la nation d'Israël,"
qui à l'époque, était à un niveau assez élevé d'organisation sociale.
Maintenant, l'organisation sociale a atteint le niveau mondial, et je suppose que,
s'il y a une bonne nouvelle que je peux vous annoncer, c'est que
tout ce dont le salut du monde a besoin est une quête intelligente
d'auto-intérêt disciplinée et respectueuse.
Ça va être dur. Mais on devrait quand même essayer
car on est arrivés trop loin pour tout foutre en l'air maintenant.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)